growing up South Asian or Basie there
was always one name that you knew when
you heard it it meant business Patel the
surname Patel has literally become
synonymous with business especially
hotels in the United States over
one-third of hotels are owned by Indians
70% of whom have the last name for tail
it's been called the Patel hotel
phenomenon hotels the Patel fication of
the American hospitality industry so how
did this all even start how did Indian
Americans especially those from the
Indian state of Gujarat with the last
name Patel end up owning almost 40% of
the hotel industry I'm sana this is a j+
and this is a story of the Patels of
america and the story of the struggles
and successes of immigrant communities
[Music]
the story of the potato starts with an
undocumented immigrant from Mexico yep a
Gujarati man by the name of country by
decide moved from the West Indies by way
of Mexico to San Francisco in the 1920s
in the early 1940s he was living in a
residential motel called the Goldfield
which was run by a Japanese American
when FDR's executive order came down and
forced over 100,000 japanese-americans
into incarceration camps decide decided
to buy the lease from the
japanese-american owner apparently for
like a couple hundred bucks when the
United States loosened restrictions on
immigration in 1965 there was an uptick
in Indian immigration and an uptick in
Indians buying hotels and a lot of the
Indian hospitality pioneers apparently
actually stayed in Desai's hotel and
were inspired by him and because so many
were coming from farming backgrounds
back in India meaning they owned their
own land and so their own crops they
didn't want to work for anyone they
wanted to be in charge plus think of it
this way you're moving to a new country
and you need to find a way to survive
make money and you find out there are
people in this new country who maybe
share your language and experience and
they're doing something that seems
stable or successful and you've got
access to them and to their knowledge on
the how to get started details so why
not write there was also the added bonus
depending on how you see it of owning a
hotel where you didn't have to pay rent
in fact a lot of families lived and many
still do in the hotels that they manage
and the kinds of hotels they were
managing were low and middle budget
places like Motel sixes travel lodges
and Holiday Inns they would take run
down roadside properties and turn them
around and Indian Americans were pivotal
in spreading franchises like Days Inn
and Best Westerns because they were
willing to move to some of the most
remote areas of the country now Indian
Americans still dominate the low budget
sector of the hospitality industry but
there has been some movement to the
higher end of the industry take for
example the story of how supey Shah an
Indian American also Gujarati who
started with a small motel in
Pennsylvania it had 23 rooms and he and
his family lived there behind the motel
lobby that business eventually evolved
into the herschel hospitality trust
which owns about fifty-two hotels and is
worth over 2.5 billion dollars and new
Indian immigrants are still going into
the business after all the network
that's available to them in the industry
is huge but while there is this
fascination with the Patels of America
and their pioneering history in the
hotel industry they and their story are
romanticized a little too much I
actually called up poem Dhingra who
wrote the book on this topic and while
he focuses on the inspiring story of
hardworking Indian Americans in the
hotel industry he actually made some
pretty good points about how that
success hasn't come easy Indian American
have achieved a great amount but that
doesn't mean they've achieved full
belonging and acceptance people avoid
their hotels and they think Indian owned
or walk into the motel with a negative
attitude there's still stereotype that
they have to encounter till to prove
themselves as legitimate owners in the
business so the story of the Patels is
similar to the stories of countless
immigrant communities in this country
and that's the story that's more about
the struggle of living in America rather
than the dream so there you have a guy's
a quirky interesting part of American
history and the American immigrant
experience have you guys ever stayed in
a Patel and what are some other
immigrant stories that you're interested
in hearing about let us know in the
comments below and don't forget to Like
and subscribe